The thoughts.
Wait, yes you are.
I don't see the...
Yes you are.
It's right there.
Oh, hello everybody.
Talk normal so I could do a test.
Hello everybody.
From a really nice nap with my girlfriend.
We were kissing, cuddling in bed.
We were not doing that.
That is how means talk.
hi everybody hi everybody sorry i just got up from a nap so
i'm a little bit silly kooky kooky i'm a little i feel kind
of blurry i don't know do you have you kind of like blurred
out no i think you look fine no i just feel it no i'm sure i
look fine like yeah you wouldn't sabotage me or anything no
but were you gonna ask before i interrupted you rudely do
you have your teeth yes it's over to I don't want to bring
it by your technology.
You can if you want to spot.
In a bit, in a bit.
When we're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here.
Right there.
Hi, everybody.
Hi.
I don't know why, but you sang it like that was funny.
Oh, my God.
You know when you're, like, learning how to sing, they're
having you go, like, the scale.
That's what you did.
Yeah, Matara is in very 4K.
on Google yeah this is what it looks like originally who put
that there actual bug size put me on your head it's like oh
you know those memes that like it'll show like a small
picture and then enhance like a little but like a it's like
enhance I don't what gosh she doesn't know anything I your
stupid cat oh he's so stupid like i'm trying to be nice
yesterday i was polite because i had just met um have you
said his name yeah jonathan mr jonathan i had just met him
yesterday and i was very nice and today i'm like jonathan
jonathan he's being naughty today he would run into me and
then like meow i'm like i'm standing still your cat runs
into me bumps into me And then meows at me, and I'm like,
you did this.
You, you.
At one point, I was walking, and I had my tea.
Well, the tea you made me, and I was like, Jonathan!
And you even said, you're like, you're starting to sound
like me.
I know, I was like, you're starting to sound like how I talk
to him.
Because I'm always just like, Jonathan!
Jonathan!
When will you?
When will you stop?
When will you learn?
But Dara was like, your cat will one day be smart.
Maybe.
In another life.
one no he's very cute he's very sweet he's so but he's so
he's so sweet yeah he's very nice jonathan akiba jonathan
akihabra is his full name oh that's good that's good he also
took a really big liking i gave minto some evil momos oh yes
and he's been like oh my god he's going feral over evil momo
he's like carrying him around in his mouth and like jumping
around and going crazy we came home and there was just evil
Momo by the door with his butt out like oh no they had some
fun he was hopefully it was a good boy while we were gone we
went to a museum today did we can't tell you much more about
that though because we're trying to trying to keep it
private here in Akihabara in Akihabara yeah virtual in a
kihabata virtual land but it was great i did say something
to mint when i had just woken up we're basically at a
certain point i thought she was breathing kind of loud at
the museum and i was gonna turn around be like hey mint you
know you're breathing kind of loud but it was a lady like
her i don't know her walker or something it made a sound
that was like like it did that kind of sound and and i at a
certain point remember being like oh mint is kind of mouth
breathing like that's really not like her like i don't know
And as a friend, I'm that friend that if you have like
something in your teeth or you have like, I'll be like, hey,
by the way, like you have some lipstick on your teeth.
You have this.
I'm not going to yell at you.
I'm not going to be like, hey, girl.
By the way, you're breathing really, really loud.
But I was going to like tell you and then I realized it was
the lady.
The lady on her wheelchair.
No, I wasn't breathing loudly.
No, she wasn't.
She wasn't.
But it's funny because I was petting Johnny earlier and I
watched.
He likes, he's a mouth breather.
And I watched him.
I watched him.
He was like, I was petting him.
And he goes, I'm like, with this mouth.
And I was like, like, slowly mouth breathing.
I was like, ew.
Yeah.
He's very, very cute.
He's, I can see why, you know, he's so silly.
I had, like, a little strand of hair down.
And he was playing with my strand of hair.
I know.
He's very silly.
I think you missed most of his craziness with Evil Momo.
So hopefully he gets the zoomies again.
into my um yeah also when you ask me what kind of cup i
drink my tea from that kind of cup oh she kept seeing my
cups are small mint gave me a cup that to give you all an
idea i put evil momo next to the cup to take a photo and
evil momo's bigger than the cup no and i was like that's my
big cup yeah her big cup is like baby sized no it's not it's
not even that small okay come on okay in that It's all
slander, that's the size of your cup.
No, it's not.
Also, I sent this to my mom.
I was like, that's my sleeping spot.
She took a picture of my figures and it's just Ayami Mama's
butt out.
Right by my head.
Also, we had corn sushi yesterday.
It was very good.
Corn sushi.
Her favorite.
Yeah.
We had sushi together.
Today we got ramen together.
that's it that's it that's it oh i thought you were gonna do
your joke i feel like i've already done it so many times go
on okay do it for the everybody um um it sounds like oh i
just woke up also it's funny your pants they say They, um,
spades, like ace of spades, but there's not spades on them.
That's what that means?
Yeah.
It's spade in French.
Gelato pique is like a peak.
Peak is a spade.
I say peak too, but they'll correct you in Japan.
That's fine.
Oh, they say pique.
Yeah, they say pique.
It's gelato pique.
Mm-hmm.
But yeah, I've read, this gelato pique is very popular brand
in Japan.
It's very nice.
But they have like all sorts of, I guess, well, now I know.
Wait, so it's gelato spade.
spades I think it's kind of maybe it's peak like so peak is
also um stinging when you when you sting something why is
the gelato stinging me also I have a funny tidbit that I
randomly realized yesterday yeah I realized so in French
roller coasters it's Russian mountains yeah and then I
actually looked it up and it's true it's because like in in
Russia they I didn't know I just found that out in Russia
they would build these like you know kind of like mountains
with snow and then they would slide down them and then when
it got it came to france and they build roller coasters of
how it started and that's what they're called russian
mountains wait how is it how do you say it in french
montaigne grus yeah montaigne russ montaigne russ how's your
day how's it feel to have me around loving amazing show
stopping oh as as a treat as it usually is Yeah, we've been
laughing like...
Ducks.
We've been going like...
It's been great.
In Russia, roller coaster is American mountains.
Is that true?
American ski gorky.
What the heck?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Whose mountains are they?
What are we doing?
Why did we say like our gorky, like our mountains?
Our mountains.
not your mat wait no our mountain yeah i don't know i don't
know we're gonna do karaoke today you guys yeah we are i'm
excited what are you gonna sing for them i you go first oh i
it's gonna be great i do want to warn everybody i sing
depressive songs even when i'm in a good mood so she does i
hope you're ready to cry oh yeah oh everybody ready to cry
get it we get ready get the tears Ask Mata what shagohad
means.
Shagohad.
Actually, she was reading some of my Metal Gear stuff.
Yeah, she had like a box and I was like, wait, this says a
package.
And I was like, why?
And then I realized it was a Metal Gear box.
Oh, yeah.
It's my...
Manta has so much Metal Gear stuff.
I already knew that, but...
It's my...
What's the tissue box?
It's a Metal Gear tissue box.
She's obsessed.
She has Metal Gear back.
She has boxes.
She has everything.
She has Hideo Kojima's skull.
I do.
Like his real skull from when he passed away.
She has it.
No, you're not supposed to tell him that.
I said that and then I felt, yeah, I take it back.
I take it back.
Kojima's going to live forever.
Oh, no, I was thinking like he was now a robot, but nobody's
supposed to know.
Sorry, I'm not supposed to say this was like classified W of
the information that he passed away and this is actually an
AI replacing him.
And that's why he's like still working on games because his
conscience will never stop working.
He will never stop working.
Yeah, he put his consciousness into a robot.
Yeah, he put it in Google.
In Google.
It lives in Google.
Uh-oh.
Kajimbo GPT, exactly.
You killed him?
No, no, no, no.
Well, no.
She's pretty vicious.
You'd be surprised.
No, Sony did that.
Oh, too soon.
Too soon.
Girl.
Although it's fine because you can make that joke because
you're already about back if he hadn't bounced back if it
was just like he got you know then you couldn't yeah yeah
yeah no he uh he's fine i'm excited for fizzin i'm excited
that what do you know about it tell me i don't think any i
don't think there's really anything oh so all we know is
just it's supposed to be the spiritual successor yes cool
i'm excited also guys let me know how audio is because
matara's using her own her own mic and i am also using my
can you hear us if we talk at the same
I walked and I The fox The quick brown fox Jumped over Laura
Mipson Laura Mipson I saw you had that on your schedule It
was on accident But it's so perfect That it was for today I
thought it was on purpose Laura Mipson Laura Mipson Stream
description here Stream description here Is a good one I'm
stealing that Enter your text here Is another good one Enter
your text here You can hear both at the same time.
Are we like left and right ear or no?
I don't think so.
I was actually thinking of doing that.
I was like if I put you all away on the other side of the
room.
Think of like how it would feel if it's like we try to do it
good but it ends up being like really really bad where it's
like I sing one thing and you say another thing and it just
feels like demons.
Oh dear.
On your head you're like please.
I'm so overwhelmed.
I'm the I'm the devil on your shoulder and she's the angel
on your shoulder or wait you would actually our maid cafe I
was the angel you were the devil I was the devil the voices
the voices what do they mean but yeah I'm excited I'm
excited for today I will say we just took a nap we just
napped and I found this like sometimes when you're napping
it takes a while but I found I don't know what happened I
found like a magic spot on the couch and I just I was out
she was out hold you're gonna be like that tonight oh yeah I
can't wait she can't wait you guys your cat I will say it
did wake me up a few times this morning I'm sorry I told you
I warned you yeah it does your cat does this thing I feel
like it's all cats where I'm standing and your cat will just
purposely like go behind me yeah and then if I turn around
and and go behind I trip on your cat he's so clingy he is I
like so clingy I like that.
Yeah.
Has he drooled on you yet?
No.
And I haven't had a stinky breath.
So that's good.
Oh, lucky.
I know.
Yesterday when he ate and he came to you with a stinky
breath.
I'm like, hey, hey.
Will this be art carved?
Yes.
Also, stop.
What?
Stop drooling?
No.
Breathing?
Breathing.
Stop breathing.
Stop hijacking.
Stop possessing my spirit body.
Oh, am I accidentally?
possessing you.
Be me.
Oh, my oh my god.
Sorry, I didn't mean to.
I'll move to the side.
Get out of here.
Skidaddle.
Get out.
Isn't it small?
Like it feels too small to be in?
Oh, no.
I love the closet setup.
No, I mean, I meant me.
Oh.
Wait, what do you mean?
I thought you were like asking me how I feel about you my
body yes you have a very small and pleasant body I don't
know what to tell you if I speak I am in trouble you have a
very bodacious body bodacious girlfriend you're very
bodaciously beautiful okay let's sing let's sing what do you
want me to say what do you want to sing can I get what's my
warm-up can I get one basket case by the green day.
Basket case.
Yeah.
It's a good warm-up song.
Also, hopefully you guys don't hear the audio.
We don't have speakers.
Or we don't have.
No, and if you do, we just put it really quiet.
All right, everybody.
If you know, sing along.
Um, I'm going to put on reverb.
Thank you so they don't hear my naked voice singing.
Oh.
Oh wait, how?
Wait!
Why can't I hear us?
I forgot you didn't have compression on it.
Hopefully your audio is still okay.
Wait, just talk normal.
Hello?
Okay, sorry.
Yes, I'm talking normally.
This is me regularly speaking.
Okay, that should be fine.
Oh my god.
My energy's coming back.
Do you have the time to listen to me?
About nothing and everything all I want.
Why do you keep all the PIP?
Melodramatic fools.
Yeah.
Neurotic to the bum, no doubt about it.
It, it.
Sometimes I give myself the creeps.
Sometimes my mind plays tricks on me.
It all keeps adding up.
I think I'm cracking up.
Am I just paranoid?
Am I just dumb?
I went to a shrink to analyze my dreams she says it's lack
of love that's bringing me down I went to a lady he said my
left's a boy so quit my wanting cuz it's bringing her down
sometimes I give myself the creeps sometimes my mind plays
tricks on me it all keeps at it I think I'm cracking up.
Am I just paranoid?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh.
Grasping to control.
So I better hold on.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
I like how you're just man standing.
Man spreading, man's Man-splaining!
Man-splaining!
So the joke is...
Okay.
Yeah, I'm a spy.
This is me.
Sometimes I give myself the creeps.
Creep!
Sometimes I might place tricks on me.
Me!
I think I'm cracking up.
Am I just paranoid?
Am I just dumb?
Just
lick it.
You're so silly.
Wow.
That's right, Mr. Johnny.
Come on.
Do you have something you want to say?
Jonathan.
Well said, well said.
Very brave of you.
Very brave of you to share that with us.
Thank you, Jonathan.
Oh, he's just laying on the ground.
He just wants to be with us.
It was a very important message.
It wasn't me.
You hold the mic up to me.
She's out here.
Meem!
Johnny!
He's so cute right now.
He's getting pets.
You wish that was you, huh?
Matara likes how cross-eyed he is.
think yeah so what else what are you gonna sing i don't know
what about bring me to life bring me you don't need to warm
up damn you're crazy is this what do you mean because you
gotta like get there get there okay ellipse of an angel too
early too early
Eat to
verse Leak,
I'm so numb Without a soul My spirit's sleeping somewhere
cold Until you find it there and lead it back home Wake me
up!
I can't wake up Wake me up inside Call my name and save me
from the door Wake me up In my blood to run Before I come on
door Save me
Nice Help
me up Richard Call my day but save me from the door Wake me
up if I'm blood to run I can't wake up For I come, I die.
Save me.
Save me from the nothing I've become.
Bring me to life.
I've been living the life.
There's nothing inside.
Bring me to life.
All that inside without your touch, without your love.
Darling, only you are the light, Papa, the dead.
All the time.
Can't believe I couldn't see.
Captain the dark, but you were there in front of me.
I've been sleeping a thousand years, it seems.
I've got to open my eyes to everything.
Without thought, without voice, without soul.
Don't let me die here.
There must be something more.
I'm in a coma and they keep playing this song.
I've been living a life.
There's nothing in life.
Tomorrow, he's here.
He's here.
I gotta have a sip of tea.
Okay.
Oh my god, this tea is really good.
I told you.
My mama gave that to me.
Ayami, mama.
I gotta get more of it.
Oh, you might be a real mom.
No.
My mama.
Ooh, I had some ayami today.
I ate the cakes.
They were really good.
Has anybody else tried them?
Can I get a one if you've eaten the ayami cakes?
It's from Comiquet.
So probably.
maybe few hey some people go to japan because they're weeps
big weeps two two two we have a one we have a one two two
two well for all the twos let me tell you it was so
delicious it was a light spongy fluffy cake with delicious
vanilla kind of style of cream it was so you really are
missing out only one person went not to make you guys
jealous but you're really missing out i'm sorry god it was
amazing i'm kind of hungry yeah we just ate no we did wait
yes we did that's why we had the food coma no that was a
couple hours ago it was like three and a half hours ago okay
no i mean we can eat after after stream i don't know if you
can sing and eat i can't even be awake and sing
i want everybody to taste them though i wish i could i was
like how can I get more people to try these but export them
it's a food yeah it's going to be tough to export it was
really good I purposely wanted to not eat the mint ones
because they're going to be less tasty than the ayami ones
even though they all taste the same but mentally I'm like
mmm ayami tasty I told I said I made the joke it's just a
joke I said they've got more they've got more substance mmm
wait what did I say I don't listen to you I don't I don't
know.
I don't know.
Dusko!
Oh, hi Dusko.
Hi Dusko.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Do you guys have the pin that Dusko, the key charm that
Dusko made of Minto and Matara from Offkay, Mintara?
Do you guys have it?
Yeah.
One if you have it.
Four.
I'm waiting.
Okay, I see one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one.
I'm trying to think, what's an easy, chill song that I can
do, because I'm still not awake yet.
Phantom of the opera.
Speak once again.
Wait.
I went to see it with Alma.
Do you know this, do you know tribute?
I know of it, but I can't sing it.
Like I don't know it well enough.
Okay.
This is like, this is the greatest song is just a tribute,
Jag Black.
I don't know.
song in the world there was the best song in the world yeah
you were singing some tenacious it was destiny
we can go to this um yeah uh not new really um i haven't
heard it yet but i know it's like a meme the cats i saw
Hootie fruit.
Wait, what does it sound like?
Let's go, let's hear it.
You think I'm going to get a copy?
Well, let's try it.
Copyright it.
Oh my God, they take no breaks in this song.
We're going to sing Hootie Fruitie by Cat's Eye, but we
don't know it.
Hootie fruit,
fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit,
fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit.
Fruit, fruit, hey cutie cutie.
I see you looking.
Cause when I walk in the party, they like who she?
Carry my matcha.
That was us today.
I like my mochi dredged in chocolate.
Let's play some truth or death.
Tell me what time you are.
You think I'm unaware, but I know what you want.
I don't know the song.
Me neither.
I'll put it on your tongue.
I know you like that.
Hootie fruity.
Hootie.
I know you like that.
Hootie fruity on your dog.
Hootie fruity all night long.
Hootie.
All the way.
Hootie fruity every day.
Hootie fruity.
Every day.
Putty nice and juicy.
Yeah, you crave it and you're not even a putty.
Let's play some truth or dance, LB.
What time you want?
You think I'm unaware.
But I know what you want.
You came for something rare.
I'll put it on your tongue.
I know you like that.
Putty, fruity, fruity, fruity, fruity, fruity.
that.
Hootie, hootie, hootie, hootie, hootie, hootie, hootie,
hootie, hootie.
I know you like that.
Fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit,
fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit, fruit,
fruit, fruit, fruit.
I can't, fruit doesn't look like a word anymore.
It looks fake.
I was trying to emulate.
There was this like really, it was like a meme band.
I think it was called Gunther it was this guy in Germany
with two hot blondes and it was like oh you touch my tra la
la yeah and I was literally just like channeling that so you
asked what accent I was thinking like how would Gunther sing
this he'd be like hooty fruity hooty fruity like the $20
smoothies in LA yeah that was um we could do the top global
songs let's see what people are dancing queen There's cream.
Oh, there's my Wonderwall.
Come at me.
No.
You want Wonderwall?
No, no.
I'm not yet.
Are you sure?
Not yet.
It's like kind of harder for me to sing because the singer
has this like twang in his voice where he goes like.
My Wonderwall.
So I find it hard not to copy him.
You're my Wonderwall.
But it's kind of hard to find the cadence.
So I feel myself like almost I don't do it on purpose but I
kind of mock him because I like imitate his accent.
No, I get it.
I get it.
Can you keep going down please?
Yeah.
Mama Mia.
We could do Mr. Bright size.
I miss your bright size.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
I know.
Oh, that's it.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
Hit me, baby.
One more time.
I voiced it.
Yeah, me too.
A little bit.
Anything, just name it.
Yeah, I'm just, I'm looking for now.
Sorry, everybody.
I didn't really prepare my list of songs I was going to
sing.
I thought I'd just, like, shoot it from the heart.
like the hip but the heart
oh let's do iris it's like oh yeah it's yearning enough and
i'm still yearning you're you're yearning i'm a year i'm not
yearning but it's like there's like no it's perfect oh when
i was in japan i think yuzu came to visit um poni gear pause
it pause it nope and i give up forever to touch
me somehow you're the closest to heaven that i'll ever be
i'm hot and i don't want to go home right now you're making
it hard to sing me oh and all i can breathe is your life but
sooner or later it's over i just don't want to miss you And
I don't want the world to see me.
Wait, sorry, we can't really hear the music, you guys.
Stand.
When everything's made to be broken, I just want you to know
who I am.
I'm like thirsty from the ramen.
Oh.
Yeah, we couldn't hear the music because it was so well.
We were just reading the words.
And you can't fight the tears that ain't coming Or the
moment the truth in your life When everything feels like the
movies Yeah, you bleed just to know you're alive And I don't
want the world to see me Cause I don't think that they
understand When everything's made to be broken, I just want
you to know who I am.
Oh, it's next.
Oh, you're right.
So Yuzu came to visit and Onigiri and I were singing this
song.
And during this part, Yuzu was like, oh, is it done?
And then the whole time, Yuzu kept being like, oh, is it
done?
But like, no, no, no, songs in the 1900s just had like a
really long musical break.
They did.
So for us to, like,
another thing too lately my voice has been kind of stuck
high I like unable to settle my voice down I don't know why
I don't know if that ever happens no it's not a cough thing
I think it's an anxiety thing can you please not refer to it
like that the 1900s I love that people still are confused
about that
it's where the movie dialogue with because every big song
was like, oh, it's so true.
This is where they would kiss.
He's just like, I can't lose you to die.
No, but you lost me that I, you left.
Well, you chose my sister over me.
I know I made mistakes, but I've changed.
And show me, prove it.
Here, I brought the gingerbread cookie you gave me all those
nights ago.
Oh, you remember.
I remember.
I like you sometimes.
I think you're pretty cool.
And I don't want the world to see me.
Because I don't understand.
When everything's made to be broken, I just want you to know
who I am.
And I don't want the world to see me.
Cause I don't think that they'd understand When everything's
made to be broken I just want you to know who I am I just
want you to know who I am I just want you to know who I am I
just want you to know who I am
Yeah, that's all I needed to hear.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm going to eat this cookie now.
Oh, no, I'm allergic to gingerbread.
No, you know what that...
You know what that reminded me of was that girl?
You know, it's one of my favorite clips ever.
I love that clip.
I know.
It's so good.
The one where she's like, the animals are dying.
The aliens won't contact us.
The planet is dying, but I'm here, and do you really need
anything else?
Can't make me...
I actually don't know that clip.
Yeah, just show me after.
Wait, can I show you right now?
Let me drink some tea.
Yeah.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, guys, what do I search?
What do I search to find this?
Numi did that clip on Choicer Voicer?
It's on Choicer, I missed it.
a voice here bury me bury me yeah with the quick scoping
it's so good the kill yeah wait hold on the animals are
leaving oh yeah yeah yeah here we go here okay hold on i
gotta turn off this so that they can't sorry you guys can't
hear it only i can hear it yeah she'll only she'll be you'll
hear live reaction okay oh it's on twitch oh wait oh no i
need the okay i need the um do you really this one wait no
oh my gosh no is this it maybe yeah i think so it's my
favorite she has the rasp too from streaming i know right i
know
need anyone else i
have never seen that marry me marry me
it's so that rasp is like exactly what you get when you
stream for like 10 hours every day for five days straight
it's awesome bring me bury me oh that was really good thank
you for that clip i know my soul is healed i love listening
to it that's something about it is so satisfying i don't
know i think i like the rasp in her no it's literally it's
the best it's the rasp that you get from like
Would you like to give us a song?
Yeah, do you guys wanna hear anything?
Oh yeah, smart.
You guys wanna hear?
We could do Lincoln Park.
We could do Nirvana.
I know you like Nirvana.
I love Nirvana.
Wait, can you see what they have from the Nirvana?
Because I am very much, my voice isn't a Nirvana.
Some of them have like 90s words in them.
Like this one, the fifth one on the right.
I mean, it's all funny, but you know what I mean?
Some of them have 90s words, so I want to be.
No, you could sing whatever.
K-pop demon hunters.
Who do you think we are?
Yeah, how much talent do you think?
I mean, between the two of us, we have one person of talent.
We're going up.
Okay, let's do lithium.
Lithium.
I always confuse that in all apologies, but I know all
apologies, What else could I be?
It's all you.
Can you turn it up a little bit?
I think that's the one where he says everyone is gay.
I'm so happy.
Cause today I found my friends.
They're in my head.
I'm so ugly.
That's okay.
Cause so are you.
We've broken our mirrors Sunday morning.
His every day for all I care.
And I'm not scared.
Light my candles.
In a daze, cause I found God.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, yeah.
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
yeah I'm so lonely that's okay I shaved my head and I'm not
sad and just maybe I'm to blame for all I heard but I'm not
sure I'm so excited I can't wait to meet you there but I
don't care I'm so that's okay My will is good.
Hey, yeah.
Yeah.
I like it.
I'm not gonna.
I miss you.
I'm not gonna crack.
I love you.
I killed you.
I'm not gonna crack.
I like it.
I miss you.
I'm not gonna crack.
I love you.
I killed you.
I'm not gonna crack.
I like it because I don't have to wake up my voice just I'm
so happy because today I found my friends they're in my head
I'm so ugly that's okay because so are you we've broken our
mirrors
all I care and I'm not scared.
Light my candles in our days because I found God.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I like it, I'm not gonna crack, I miss you, I'm
not gonna crack, I love you, I'm not gonna crack, I killed
you, I'm not gonna crack, I like it, I'm not gonna crack, I
miss you, I'm not gonna crack, I love you, I'm not gonna
crack, I love you, I'm not gonna crack, I love you, I'm not
gonna crack, I love you, I'm not gonna crack, I like it, I'm
not gonna crack, I love you, I'm not gonna crack.
I killed you.
I'm not gonna crack.
Yeah, all Nirvana songs, if you know one, it's like
Nickelback.
You kind of know all of them.
I was like, wait, I do know this song.
Yeah.
It's all apologies where he says, everyone is gay.
Oh.
In the sun.
Everybody?
Yeah.
He says, everyone is gay.
Everyone is gay.
Everyone?
Okay, let's see.
Legends of rock.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you like sweet child of mine?
We can try it.
I'm here for the eye of the tiger too.
I'll try, I'll try my best to actually like sing it, sing it
and not be stupid.
Okay, we'll be singing.
It's really hard for me not to be stupid.
I know.
It's so tough.
I also, when I'm like with people, I'm like, I don't know.
I'm always saying serious.
I want to just be in my, that's why we're in a karaoke
booth, you guys.
Yeah.
.
memories where everything was fresh as the bright blue sky.
Sky, sky.
Now and then when I see her face she takes me away to that
special place and if I stared too long I'd probably break
down and cry.
Oh,
sweet child of mine.
Whoa, oh, oh, oh, sweet love of mine.
She's got eyes of the bluest skies as if they got part of
brain.
I'd hate to look into those eyes and see.
Her hair reminds me of a warm safe place As a child I hide
And pray for the thunder and the rain To quietly pass me by
Whoa, sweet child of mine Oh, oh, oh, oh, sweet love of mine
That's right.
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh my god, you guys!
What happened?
She's gonna break it down!
Oh yeah, sorry, I saw the red.
Oh my god!
Stop!
Yes, stop!
It's so loud!
Here she goes!
Five bucks, right?
Stop!
Oh my god!
You're dead like me!
Sorry, sorry.
Put me down.
You're spinning around!
Put me down!
Let me go!
Oh, oh, sweet love of mine!
She's going the other way!
No!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, sweet child of mine!
Let me down!
Please, I've been here!
Ben!
Ben, sweet love of mine!
With
the cat noises.
Sorry, Johnny.
I'm not sorry.
She was lifting me with her super ghost strength.
It was crazy.
I was really scared.
It was really scary.
I miss when they have songs have like crazy songs like this.
A
band?
They don't sing.
They just make noises.
And they're from Quebec.
And they dress up in a way that I think you might.
You probably see me.
You think so?
Their name translates to like chest pains.
Where do we go now?
Where do we go?
Where do
we go now?
Can you get up here?
Where do we go?
Mercy.
Sweet child.
I don't remember how this goes here, I'm sorry.
I love mine.
My love.
Do you know any garbage?
Garbage.
The band.
Do you?
No.
Stop.
First you lift me with your super gold string.
Then you call me garbage.
Do you know garbage the band?
I don't think so.
You can sing a song and I will...
Can you see they have only happy when it rings?
my voice is yeah don't worry the cat the cat is on her so we
are all gonna have to wait for a moment oh my god you cry
sign speak okay say something say something can you guys
hear him purr he's going I think he's he's drooling and so
he's gonna look up his drool here here I'm gonna cross my
eyes too so we can be Oh, he's in here.
He was doing this a lot.
He's like laying on top of her.
This is so intimate.
Like, imagine how you wear a backpack, but he's like at the
front of me like a backpack.
Come on, Johnny.
Get off.
Go over here.
Johnny.
Johnny, come on.
You like the boobies, don't you?
You don't know how to get back to me.
No.
He kept doing that.
I will say, though, in the middle of the night, he would
like jump on me, wake me up, walk all over me, and then the
moment I, like, he'd leave me.
No, he's got like 80-ish things.
Why'd you wake me up?
Garbage.
See, they have only happy when it rains.
Only, oh, what they do.
All right, are you ready?
I'm only happy when it rains.
Oh, but I don't remember.
I'm only happy when it's complicated.
And though I know you can't appreciate it, I'm only happy
when it rains.
You know I love it when it's undue.
is bad why it feels so good so feel so sad I'm only happy
when it rains sorry guys I don't remember how this song goes
pour your misery down pour your misery down on me pour your
misery down on me I'm a only happy when it rains.
I feel good when things are going wrong.
I only listen to the sad, sad songs.
I'm only happy when it rains.
That's one of my big things is I don't remember how songs
go.
So I have to like... That's one of my big things.
No, I genuinely don't remember how I only smile in the dark.
My only comfort is the night gone black.
I didn't accidentally tell you that.
I'm only happy when it rains.
You'll get the message by the time I'm through.
When I complain about me and you.
I'm only happy when it rains Next being held like a baby
Pour your misery down Pour your misery down on me Pour your
misery down Pour your misery down on me Pour your misery
down Pour your misery down on me Pour your misery down You
can keep me company As long as you don't care I'm only happy
when it rains You wanna hear about my new obsession I'm
riding high upon a deep depression
Down.
I'm only happy when it rains.
I'm gonna try this.
I'm only happy when
it rains.
Sun, misery down.
I'm sure you've heard of this band.
They were really big in the 2000s.
1900s.
Maybe.
There was a song called Cherry Lips.
Cherry Lips.
With your cherry lips and golden curls, you could make
grown.
Oh, it's Stupid Girls, their most famous one.
What do you want to sing?
I don't know.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, wait, what did you guys want to hear?
Why am I low pixel?
That's just what I look like.
Put your glasses on.
Yeah.
song that was on the MGSV trailer.
What?
Oh, which song?
Which one?
I don't know.
Brum.
What are you doing over there?
He's complaining.
Johnny's complaining behind us.
Oops, my jacket is wrong.
Noor.
I see somebody saying another Nirvana.
Nirvana.
You guys want to be depressed?
I'm down.
Nobody's answering my question.
Yeah, they hate you.
I know.
Yeah.
We could do the one song.
Wait, do you know nuclear?
Let's see.
If I do, I'll sing along.
Yeah, this one was in the metal gear.
You want to come back to me?
You are so...
I'm going to do plus two though.
Okay.
So just follow along with me.
I will.
Standing on the edge of the crater.
like the prophets once said and the ashes are all cold now
no more bullets and the embers are dead whispers in the air
tell the tales of the brothers gone.
Desolation, devastation, what a mess we made when it all
went wrong.
Watching from the edge of the circus for the games to begin.
Johnny's not a radiator.
No.
Oh, out.
Sorry for biting you.
Blow their brains.
Oh my goodness.
I'm nuclear.
I'm
breaking up inside.
A heartless defiled Deep inside the abandoned child
Standing on the edge of the underworld Looking at the abyss
And I'm hoping for some miracle break out to escape from all
this.
Whispers in the air tell the tales of a life that's gone.
Desolation, devastation, what a mess we made When it all
went wrong I'm nuclear I'm wild I'm breaking up Inside A
heart of broken glass Defiled Thank you Jacko Jacko
It's because I don't know the song, so I don't want to lead.
I'm just trying to like fit in.
Wow.
I'm just trying to fit in.
Yeah, that's literally me.
I'm just trying to fit
in.
Guys, I'm already here.
I'm already chaser.
I'm nuclear.
I'm one.
up inside a heart of broken glass deviled deep inside the
abandoned child deep
inside the abandoned child
yes what yes are you trying to He's trying to eat my pants.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What are you saying, Jordan?
Maybe I shouldn't have been smoking cigarettes before this.
I got a pack of Japanese mentols from Japan.
So I've been, hey, hey, hey.
That's the wire.
You're not allowed to eat it.
You can if you want to.
It's close to his feed time.
I'll take care of them.
You know I will.
You will.
You know I'll take good care of them.
I'm scared.
Don't be, they should be scared, not you.
Right.
With.
You should be scared.
Stop it.
You should be very scared, everybody.
Yeah.
If you want to go feed him, go, go.
I'm playing with him now.
I'm playing with the string on my pants.
I'll sing some depressive songs while you're gone.
That was a depressing song.
You should learn it.
That was very depressing.
Like, how does the original go then?
It's just a little.
Oh.
How like load is it?
Oh, it's a guy singing.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I want to hear.
Standing.
oh on the edge of the crater like the prophets once said
yeah yeah this is fine and the ashes are all cold now I
don't know what this I never heard this all are dead are
dead and the embers are all dead I went up but was into the
ring of fire down down down and the flames are getting
higher wait what is that Johnny cat I think Johnny cash ring
of fire yeah yeah yeah I really should learn like a what is
it the Frank Sinatra song which one I don't know but I feel
like I could probably hit it pretty good I don't know how
low they go but I could probably hit some of them with my
voice.
You know fly me to the moon.
Fly, but it goes, I only, the thing is when I think of it, I
think of a female cover.
Fly me to the moon.
And let me date, play among the stars.
The hardest thing I feel like when you're listening to a man
sing is I wanna like always do it higher.
I know.
Cause I'm like, oh, it should be, like it's gonna sound
better higher, but like, no.
Well, sometimes I just get on this and I just practice songs
at different like.
Yeah, yeah, that's smart.
With different keys so that it's, that's live do you want to
do something fun and emo yeah what's fun and emo do you want
to do um do you want to do what is it called what are they
called um my chemical romance or do you want to do fallout
men you can do my chemical okay Rome my chemical Rome what
do you want Helena no I want to do I feel it's either face
famous last rest of now I know that or sharpest life
sharpest life is kind of hard if I remember which one do you
know how about this I know a couple of them well like I I
think I would maybe remember I don't remember them my name I
might remember them if I heard try putting famous last words
it's a long one and I'm sure you're gonna yeah I know this I
think so okay you think I'm pretty no kidding I know that I
can't make you stay but where's your heart but where's your
heart but where's your and I know there's nothing I can say
I'll go feed him to change I'll sing something else that
we'll sing this when you're back or we'll sing it out that
part to change I don't want to sing another one that she's
not gonna I want to see if I remember this one.
Sorry, everybody.
I don't know if I remember this one, but we'll go.
Well, it rains and it pours when you're out.
Crash on the couch.
Can I sleep in my clothes?
Because I spend the night dancing.
I'm drunk, I suppose.
If it looks like I'm laughing, I'm really just asking.
This alone, you're in time for the show.
You're the one that I need.
I'm the one that you love.
You can watch me corrode like a beast in repose Cause I love
all the poison away with the boys in the band I've really
been on a bender and it shows So why don't you blow me a
kiss before she goes?
Give me a shot to remember And you can take all the pain
away from me Your kiss and I will surrender The sharpest
lives are the deadliest to love How light to burn on the
empires So bright the sun is ashamed to rise And be in love
with all of these vampires So you can live like the saint
abandoned me Ow!
There's a place in the dark where the animals go You can
take off your skin in the cannibal glow Juliet loves the
beast and the lustic amass Drop the dagger and the...
Oh my god, the blood on your hands, Romeo I've really been
on a pender and it shows.
So why don't you blow me a kiss before she goes?
Give me a shot to remember.
And you can take all the pain away from me.
A kiss and I will surrender.
The sharpest lives are the deadliest to lead.
A light to burn all the empires.
So bright the sun is a shame to rise and be in love with all
of these vampires so you can live like the saint abandoned
me he just doesn't breathe mint has such an amazing vocal
range she sounds like matara i know mint is so good i mean
thank you everybody they said you have such an amazing vocal
range you sound like me oh because i needed to read what he
wrote oh my god give me a shot And you can take all the pain
away from me.
You can say love is surrender.
The sharpest lives are the deadliest to lead.
And life's to burn all the empires.
So bright the sun is a shame to rise and be in love with all
of these vampires.
So you can leave like the saint abandoned me.
Yeah, he like doesn't breathe.
Oh my god, I can tell.
I'm dribbling the sweat when I catch it.
No.
Oh, I can see it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wait, Ashley.
Wait, stop.
Are you hot?
Wait.
A little bit warm.
The fan's not on.
It's because I have my sweatpants on.
I should have put shorts on instead.
You want the fan on?
Yeah.
Can you feel it?
Oh, okay.
I've been totally cozy.
Big booty problem.
sweating just my boobies yay did you feed him the shekin
yeah I fed him the shekin hold on I gotta drink more tea
okay guys what should I sing I think you should sing snake
eater snake eater okay I'll sing snake eater I think I saw
somebody wait let me just put on shorts one second I'm gonna
sing it
What a thrill with darkness inside.
Elmo voice now.
Nice.
What a thrill.
I'm searching and I'm melting to you.
So happy right now.
What a fear in my heart.
Oh, surprise.
I get my...
I can't sing seriously.
I won't look at you.
But for you.
You have to do the sticky in your part.
And my time...
There'll be no one else.
Crime.
away.
I fly to you.
Wow.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eaters.
Wow.
That was really good.
Someday, through the rain, oh.
Someday, you feed on a tree frog.
This ordeal The trial to survive For the day we see new life
I give my life
In my time There'll be no one
I'm still in a dream Snake it all
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eaters.
Nice.
That was really nice.
Yeah.
I was really enjoyable.
You did really nice.
Wow.
Thanks.
That's the good stuff.
Good soup.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks.
My voice is not good today, though.
Your voice is great.
Are you kidding me?
You held all the notes.
Oh.
I get you.
It hurts today.
It's crazy when I hear somebody sing that like knows how to
connect their chest and their head voice.
Because you're just doing like a high note, but I can hear
that you're doing it like properly.
So because of that.
Well, yeah.
Well, like so it doesn't, like if I do a high note and I
don't know how to connect it, like it's not in my head.
I do it from like falsetto or I do it from under.
Singing is weird.
yeah I've been learning how to do it and it just feels like
I'm wearing a helmet because it like goes into your face
kind of the air and it's weird and I'm like it is it takes
me out of it you sing you got to go through your diaphragm
you know which is why lately I've been kind of just stuck
singing lower songs because I I just keep it there but then
I go too low well like because I get too lazy oops what did
I just press nothing um what was it uh what because I like
did theater and stuff for so long and they tell you to like
project and do everything your diaphragm like i find myself
breathing more through it than like you know because with
your lungs you like yeah you're in your chest but like when
you breathe through your diaphragm it's like in your tummy
so yeah happy birthday melody happy birthday melody melody
melody melody melody speaking of melody what guys what
should we say i saw until people were if you know dolly part
I do, but I don't think I can sing it.
You don't?
Not even- I only know Jolene.
Yeah, but even then, I'll sing along.
Jolene.
I'll copy what you're doing.
Try it.
Jolene.
I'll just be like, Jolene.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll follow you.
I'll follow your- I think it's good.
I think it's great.
I still don't know where like all the notes are in my face,
so it's hard for me to like do a note that I'm not used to
doing.
That's okay.
Ah!
Oh,
that's my head.
Min Phantom, Min Phantom, Min Phantom, Min Phantom, I'm
begging of you please don't take my man.
Snake, no.
Big mom, I don't know.
Min Phantom, Jolene, Jolene.
Please don't take him just because you can.
This is me and to you about my cat.
Your beauty is beyond compare.
Flavin' locks of awkward hair with ivory skin And eyes of
emerald green.
Me and me.
No!
Your smile is like a breath of spring Your voice is soft
like summer rain And I cannot compare with you, Jolene.
He talks about you in his sleep.
And there's nothing I can do to keep from crying When he
meows your name.
Matara.
And I can easily understand how you could easily take my
cat.
But don't you know that he needs me?
Matara.
Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara, I'm begging of you.
Please don't take my cat.
Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara.
just because you can.
You could have your choice of cats, but I could never love
again.
He's the only one for me, Matara.
I had to have this talk with you.
My happiness depends on you.
I'm going to make you decide to do, Matara.
Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara, I'm begging of you, please
don't take my cat.
Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara, please don't take it here
even though you can.
Say it wrong words.
Learn to read, learn to read.
Oh my God.
Matara, Matara, I don't know.
Matara.
Matara, please don't take my cat.
legally I can't take your cat back to Canada so you're safe
I definitely want something from the 1900s but I don't know
what from the 1900s
pop rock do you remember the one where it's like if I go
crazy then will you still call me Superman oh yeah what is
that one I think it's kryptonite oh yeah kryptonite I think
it's at the K because it's like the Superman's will you be
there I feel like a lot of those rock songs from the early
2000s like instead of they kind of sing very nasal like if I
go crazy well you still come east they kind of sing like
that they do they do if I'm alive and well will you be there
holding my hand sorry I just remembered Donatello
Well, I took a walk around the world to ease my troubled
mind.
I left my party lying somewhere in the sands of time.
I watched the world flow to the dark side of the moon.
I feel there's nothing I can do.
Yeah.
Oh gosh, I haven't heard this song in so long.
Yeah, I don't even know that part.
I watched the world float to the dark side of the moon.
After all, I knew it had to be something to do with you.
I really don't mind what happens, you know.
As long as you'll be my friend.
Don't touch me.
If I go crazy, then will you still call me Superman?
If I'm alive and well, will you be there holding my hand?
I'll keep you by my side with my superhuman, my kryptonite.
Yeah!
Three, two, one, and go!
You called me strong, you called me weak, but still your
secrets I will keep.
You took for granted all the times I never let you down.
You stumbled in and bumped your head.
If not for me, then you'd be dead.
I picked you up and put you back on solid ground.
If I go crazy, then will you still call me Superman?
If I'm alive and well, will you be there holding my hand?
I'll keep you by my side with my superhuman.
My superhuman, my kryptonite.
Yeah!
Good.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Take each other.
Fight each other.
Yeah!
If I go crazy, then will you still call me Superman?
If I'm alive and well, will you be there holding my hand?
I'll keep you by my side with my superhuman, my kryptonite.
Yeah!
If I go crazy then will you still call me Superman?
If I'm alive then well will you be there?
Holding my hand I'll keep you by my side with my superhuman,
my kryptonite.
Linkin Park?
Let's do it.
Click Linkin Park.
Let's see what they have.
I am.
But I've never had a doubt.
It's like no matter what I do.
I like breaking the habit.
Okay, let's do it.
Let's do breaking the habit.
I like all of them, but you know.
After the big break.
Oh, this is the big break.
I'm just...
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, go, go.
Yeah.
Memories consumed like opening the wound.
again.
You all assume I'm safe here in my room unless I try to
start again.
I don't want to be the one the battles always choose cuz
inside I realize that I'm the one confused.
I don't know what's worth fighting for or why I have to
scream.
I don't know why I instigate to say what I don't mean.
I don't know how I got this way, I know it's not alright So
I'm breaking the habits I'm breaking the habits tonight I
thought it was habit, but I guess it's habits?
Clutching my cure I tightly lock the door I try to catch my
breath again I heard much more than any time before I had no
options left again I don't want to be the one the battles
always choose Cause inside I realize that I'm the one
confused I don't know what's worth fighting for Why I have
to scream I don't know why I instigate to say what I don't
mean way I'll never be alright so I'm breaking the habit I'm
breaking the habit tonight I'll paint it on the walls
because I'm the one that falls and
this is how it ends I don't know what's worth fighting for
Or why I have to scream But now I have some clarity To show
you what I mean I don't know how I got this way I'll never
be alright So I'm breaking the habits I'm breaking the habit
I'm breaking the habit Tonight
I am gonna kill myself tonight, not in Minecraft.
Oh, not in my place.
Damn.
She got me.
Ah, ma-ma.
Don't kill yourself.
You're too sexy.
Your boobie's too sweaty.
Too sweaty.
Wow.
Die not allowed here because, yeah, because we don't need...
We gotta play Minecraft.
We don't...
Yeah, we gotta play Minecraft.
We gotta play Minecraft.
I can't die.
Die after Minecraft.
Die after Minecraft, exactly.
Die after Minecraft has finished its last update.
It's like, I'm gonna die another day.
It's like, I'm gonna die after Minecraft.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
You wanna do Somewhere I Belong?
Somewhere I Belong.
And I've got nothing to say.
I can't believe I didn't fall right down on my face.
I was confused.
I don't think I know it.
It's okay.
You can do it though.
You can do it.
I'll do another one.
We don't have to do it in the park.
Can you look at Nico back, please?
Do you have a favorite Nico back?
I don't listen.
Oh, shame.
No.
Okay.
Can we, is that, which one is that?
Animals.
I don't even know.
I had an ex best friend that I'm not friends with anymore
that was her favorite song.
Oh.
And she like talked bad about me at my work and got me fired
at the restaurant.
Oh my god.
So the song has very...
Fuck you, Kirsten.
I used a fake name, don't worry.
I imagine.
Angelica.
She loved the song.
I don't actually know how the song goes.
I'm driving back on black.
Just got my license back.
I got this feeling and my veins are straight.
It's coming off the track.
I'll ask for the light if the devil...
...needs the red because...
...honey ain't it not with me tonight.
Lay up.
Can we do either saving me?
saving me, oh saving me.
Or someday.
Or how you remind me of it.
I think I know this one.
Oh yeah, I know this one.
This is my favorite nickel pack.
Prison gates won't open up for me on these hands and knees
I'm crawling.
Oh, I reach for you.
I know you've seen song songs.
Oh, well, I'm terrified of these four These iron bars can't
hold my soul And all I need is you Please, I'm calling No, I
scream for you We are falling Show me what it's like Less
ones standing Teach me wrong from right And say it for me
Say it to me, I'll leave, I went me, say it if it's worth
saving me.
My voice is tired.
Heaven's gates won't open up for me.
With these broken wings I'm falling all I see is you.
Two, one, two, two.
These city walls ain't got no love for me.
I'm on the ledge of this 18-story, oh, I scream.
For you three are calling all I need from you, hurry, I'm
falling, I'm falling, show me what it's like, and teach me
wrong from right.
And say it for me, say it to me, I'll leave this life behind
me, say it if it's me.
We're saving me!
Save me, really, really, really, really.
Guitar!
Start to sound like me.
My pickup truck.
My Chevrolet.
Chevrolet.
Oh!
Yeah.
Take my Chevy to the levee, but the levee was dry.
What's a levee?
And all I need is you.
Well in doubt, lady.
But she was dry.
And do.
Is it?
Show me what it's like.
Show me what it's like to be the last one standing.
Teach me wrong from right.
I'll show you what I can.
And say it for me, say it to me.
This life behind me, say it if it's worth saving.
me and say it for me say it to me i'll leave this life
behind me saying if this works save me have you seen those
tick tocks where it's like photos of me and my millennial
like me but i'm like 25 in 2012 in new york millennial core
no and it's always playing these songs that were like big in
the 2000s like don't listen to oh you like those i want to
do one of the are you are you getting like sad millennial
i'm getting millennial core like oh when i was 25 and it's
like it's like
so i'm trying to think what song would
trying to think what songs would be like millennial core
here we can go to the just the 90s hold on
90s mm-hmm creep no we got zombie in your head go down go
down I'm surprised you don't like iris do we saying iris
already oh you're right you crazy oh my god you're right
that's why I was thinking all the small things we could
easily do that after if you want to.
Celine Dianna singing again.
Oh, awesome.
Cool.
I mean, she's, I love her.
She had, like, some disease that made it, so she couldn't
sing for so long, and now she can sing again.
She's back in concert, you guys.
It's so true.
Dead speak.
I know.
I went to see them at the sphere.
It was great.
Whoa!
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, you told me that.
You told me that.
I don't want to run.
Oh, Depeche Mud.
Can I sing you some Depeche Mud?
Do you want to sing it with me?
Can you click?
Yeah, but not that song in particular.
Can you do Personal Jesus?
Just click the band.
You can.
Oh, you can.
Then yeah, look it up.
Depeche Mud.
I'm sure you know Personal Jesus.
Feel free to.
Do I?
I want to sing it because I probably showed you this band.
It's one of my favorite bands.
I think you did, yeah.
I like it because I can just relax my voice.
Okay.
touch faith oh yeah you show me this one a lot of their
songs like let me show you the world in my eyes i think it
like unfortunately their album is called the violator so
it's like a weird album to recommend your own personal jesus
someone to hear your prayers someone who cares Your own
personal Jesus.
Someone to hear your prayers, someone who's there.
All alone, flesh and bone, bought a telephone.
Lift up the receiver, I'll make you a believer.
Take second best, we'll be to the test.
things on your chest that you need to confess.
I will deliver you.
You know I'm a forgiver.
Reach out and touch faith.
Personal Jesus.
Someone hear your prayers.
Someone who cares.
Your own personal Jesus Someone to hear your prayers Someone
who's there
Feeling unknown and you're all alone Flesh and bone by the
telephone Lift up the receiver or make you a believer I will
deliver you know I'm a forgiver
Reaching out in touch faith Reach out in touch faith Reach
out in touch faith
Reach out and touch faith
Oh god, my voice is giving out Oh, do you want some tea?
I might take some later You have some vocals, though Oh,
yeah, that stuff smells bad, though It's okay Have you ever
smelled it before?
No It smells like the devil's lettuce
now every time I would like go some look at I've taken one
from each package wait see if they have a song called root
66 it's kind of it's still by the same band but it's kind of
like silly no this is all they've got oh really yeah darn oh
wait no oh we're 66 okay perfect a lot of their songs are
also like master and servant is literally him like let's
play master and servant the song called blue dress oh yeah
it does okay you want to try a song called blue dress he's
literally like put it on put on the blue dress i like then
take it off take it yeah these things i have are called
vocal zones you guys they're like it says they're i know
they taste good they smell bad but they taste good they
smell like the devil's lettuce but they they taste not bad
and they're sugar-free and i got recommended to them by like
a professional singer they're really nice they're okay i
like them yeah it's because i like minty it is minty okay i
haven't heard the song in a while so you guys are gonna have
to forgive me but it's like really fun you'll see what i
mean it's a little bit different from their original songs
it's not as like dark and weird it's how i learned a lot of
american cities so i know about idaho idaho yeah idaho i'm
wanting to remember how it goes Well if you ever plan to
motor west.
Seems like very different.
Come my way, take the highway, that's the best.
Get your kicks on Route 66.
Oh wait, I think I heard this song before.
Well it winds from Chicago to LA.
I legit haven't heard the song in 20 years, so forgive me.
I'm on cars.
Thousand miles all the way.
It's in cars.
It is.
Get your gigs on route 66.
Everybody knows this song from cars.
Well, it goes to St. Louis, down to Missouri.
Oklahoma City looks so, so pretty.
You'll see.
I'm a real old.
I'm a re...
Wait, I don't write New Mexico.
Down with New Mexico.
Black stuff.
Arizona, don't forget Winona, King Manitoba, San Bernardino.
If you...
I don't remember this song.
This kind of tip.
I'm sorry, guys, I don't remember it.
And go take that California trip.
Get your kicks on Route 66.
On Route 66.
We're driving, we're chilling.
I really recommend this band, y'all.
It's great.
It does sound kind of Halloweeny now, I get it.
Well, it goes to St. Louis, down to Missouri.
Oklahoma City looks so, so pretty.
You'll see.
Amarillo.
Yeah.
Mexico Flagstaff, Arizona Don't forget Winona Kingdom of the
Stones San Bernardino If you get hip to this kind of tip And
go take That California trip Get your kicks On Route 66 Get
your kicks on Route 66.
Get your kicks on Route 66.
66!
Get your kicks!
I'm sorry.
Get your kicks on Route 66.
I know.
Your turn, I feel like it's only me picking the songs.
Oh, okay.
Let's do a Mambo number five.
Is that the one where he's like naming all the ladies?
Yeah, yeah.
I'll follow.
Okay.
Ladies and gentlemen, this is Mambo number five.
Three,
two, one.
One, two, three, four, five.
Everybody in the car, so come on, let's ride to the liquor
store.
Yes.
Around the corner, the boys.
I want some gin and juice, but I really don't want to whip
us like I had last week.
I must stay deep because talk is cheap.
I like Angela, Pamela, Sandra, and Rita.
And as I continue, you know, they're getting sweeter.
So what can I do?
I really beg you my way to be flirting.
It's just like it's for.
Anything's fly.
It's all good.
I'm enjoying this.
It's okay.
Send it to the trumpet.
Little Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica by my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Minto all night long.
A little bit of Jessica here I am.
A little bit of you makes me a man.
I like flustering her.
It's very easy.
.
Jump up
and down and move it all around.
Shake your head to the south.
Put your hands on the ground.
Take one step left and one step right.
One to the front and one to the side.
Clap your hands once, clap your hands twice.
And if it looks like this, then you're doing it right.
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica by my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary all night long.
A little bit of Jessica, here I am.
A little bit of you makes me a man.
Do you think they'd hate us if we sang at Christmas?
Yeah, we can sing at Christmas.
Please, miss.
Please, ma'am.
The trumpet!
A little bit of Monica in my life A little bit of Erica by
my side A little bit of Rita's all I need A little bit of
Tina's what I see A little bit of Sandra in the sun A little
bit of Mary all night long.
A little bit of Jessica, here I am.
A little bit of you makes me a man.
I don't...
All to fall in love with a girl like you.
Because you can't run and you can't hide.
You and me gotta touch the sky.
Because he names all these women in the song, sometimes what
I do on the street, well, not porn, but you know.
I'll just be like, what's up, Brian?
Yeah, everything's okay, Jonathan, and I'll just randomly
name male and female names.
And everyone's like, wait, are you talking to me?
You, yeah, I see you.
Thank you, Jessica, how's it going?
Jimmy.
Yeah, Neutron.
Neutron.
What's another name?
Angela.
Jessica.
Casey.
Carl.
Weezer.
That's a band.
could you look up christmas is christmas look up genres yeah
i'm gonna see if there's like i think genres would have
christmas you want to see what's top in france sure
i'll go where you go nocturnal confessions all these are
french the demon of midnight well you said france what did
you think was gonna happen girl let me tell you if you go to
top italia It's going to be Beep Best little what Best
little what Read the name In your mind Second song After All
I Want for Christmas Heart candy Christmas The best little
The best little Horror House Oh my god Who's that I don't
know I've never heard of them I've never heard of them I
don't really know I only know Jingle bells really Why did
you ask for Christmas I know Last Christmas I gave you my I
think that's what I'm very next day and give it away.
I don't know how to tell you this, but at Christmas we watch
like Russian songs and movies.
Oh, they don't have jingle bells.
Not really.
They don't have, oh here's playlist Christmas.
Not the Ave Marie, this is Halloween in my Christmas
playlist.
It's the nightmare before Christmas, it counts.
It's both, it's both.
Why do you think it's cold outside?
I don't know that one really well.
I've heard it, but I don't know it.
It's a duet.
Ooh.
Do you want to build a snowman?
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Hold on.
I want to see it.
Yeah.
It's so funny because the voice is literally like, I want a
hippopotamus for Christmas.
Is it a legit song or is it like baby song?
I think it's a legit song, but it's funny because it's the
kind of or like funny yeah don't I don't think we you don't
know yeah I don't I I said that but that I actually don't
know any Christmas song I only found out that grandma got
run over by a reindeer is a real song when Zen did a cover
of it.
Oh, wow.
I was like, this is so funny.
How'd you come up with this?
It's funny, I like it.
Have you seen the music video?
It's like, they have like a grandpa, like on top of other
girls and stuff.
He's just like, oh, my grandma died.
That's weird.
Because grandpa killed grandma.
Yeah.
It's true.
Alright, guys, you can recommend some songs too, since
Matara wants to sing Christmas songs.
It doesn't know any.
so let's do not Christmas songs no no no yeah there's a
whole movie based off that song except grandpa seems too
innocent in it how did you do this then how did she came up
with that hot to go you don't know hot to go do you no but I
can sing along with you I'll it's pretty easy yeah it's like
hot to go I'll teach you the dance she includes a happy
birthday nine to five maybe later to you oh wait do you know
all the things she said yeah i know it in russian oh it's a
little high but i can do it oh well it's fine it's fine here
let's do hot to do because i think no no we can oh yeah
because i think they sing it a little bit lower yes let's
just some maybe not but yeah i'll do it okay so this is
where she's like five six okay that's not big quoting club
never mind you knew though i know this one i've heard it was
everywhere oh they do have
Yeah, yeah.
I could be the one on your new addiction.
It's all in my head, but I want nonfiction.
I don't want the world, but I'll take this city.
Who can blame a girl call me hot, not pretty?
Baby, do you like this bee?
I made it so you dance with me.
It's like 199 degrees.
Doing it with me, doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your
hand now body roll Dance it out, you're hot to go
H-O-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes It's a nice
bell H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go
H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go.
I woke up alone staring at my ceiling.
I try not to care, but it hurts my feelings.
You don't have to stare, come here, get with it.
No one's touched me there in a hot minute.
Baby, don't you like this, baby?
I made it so you'd sleep with me.
It's like 199 degrees when you're doing it with me.
with me.
H-O-T-O.
Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands on body roll.
Dance it out, you're hot to go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Snap and clap and touch your toes.
Raise your hands on body roll.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
You can take me hard to go.
What to take to get you know What's it take to bring you
home?
Hurry up, it's time for supper.
Order up, I'm hot to go.
What's it take to get your number?
Hurry up, it's time to suffer.
Order up, I'm hot to go.
You can take me hot to go.
H-O-D-D-O-T-O-G-O You
can take me hot to go.
Woo!
It's hot in here.
Ah!
What is that?
Why do you like this?
Someone said hack to go.
H-A-G-G-O-G-O.
You can take this hack to go.
I was really, I remember the song being everywhere, but I
didn't really like, I only knew the.
It's so fun, though.
It's very fun.
Which tattoo, do you want the Russian version or do you
want?
We can do the English version.
I remember some of the Russian words.
Okay, just sing the Russian parts when you want it.
I keep forgetting to do the reverb for us.
Oopsie.
Don't listen to my naked voice.
Oh my god!
Is it annoying that we're singing different words for them
or no?
I know, right?
How's it feeling?
I'm in serious shit.
I feel totally lost.
for help it's only because being with you has opened my eyes
could i ever believe such a perfect surprise i keep asking
myself wondering how i keep closing my eyes but i can't
block you out wanna fly to a place where it's just you and
me nobody else so we can be free nobody else so we can be
and I said, this is not enough.
This is not enough.
All the things she said.
No, no you're good, you're good.
I was just going to get the time to tell This is not enough.
I don't remember that.
You have to teach me the Ghost in the Shell song.
I'm in serious and in color and rush.
And they say it's my fault, but I want her so much.
Wanna fly her away with the sun and the rain Coming over my
face, wash away all the shame.
When they stop and stare, don't worry me, Cause I'm feeling
for her, what she's feeling for me.
I can try to pretend, I can try to forget, But it's driving
me mad, going out of my head.
All the things she said, all the things she said, Running
through my head, running through my head, all the things she
said, this is not enough.
This is not enough.
All the things she said, all the things she said, all the
things she said, all the things she said, all the things she
said, all the things she said, all the things she said, all
the things she said, all the things she said, all the things
she said, all the things she said, all the things she said,
all the things she said, all the things she said, all the
things she said, all the things she said, all the things she
said, all the things she said, all the things she said.
Yes such loss, so I'm mine.
Daddy, looking at me.
Will I ever be free?
Have I crossed the line?
All the things she said, all the things she said, Running
through my head, running through my head, Running through my
head, All the things she said, all the things she said,
Running through my head, running through my head, All the
things she said, this is not enough.
This is not enough.
All the things she said, all the things she said, all the
things she said, all the things she said, all the things she
said.
If I remember, in her universe she's like, Angeli, it's
angels and demons were circling in my head.
Someone didn't know you could speak Russian.
Surprise, motherfucker.
It's so cool.
Yeah, in her universe.
That's the song.
I wonder if they have it on here.
Let's see.
There's also Latin, if I remember correctly.
Is there?
Yeah.
There's Russian and Latin.
Because then she goes like...
Oh, no, they don't.
Vote for it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody go on Karafan and vote for it.
Yeah, so they'll make it into a real song, real thing.
I like my cowboys dirty.
Look at that at the bottom, at the bottom.
Whoa.
Bridget.
I didn't listen to a lot of tattoo.
I know they're not gonna get us.
That song goes like, not gonna get us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can do it if you want.
Oh, you like it?
Yep.
Do you know this one in Russian?
Um, But I don't remember the, like, the...
Yeah.
It's the same thing in Russians.
They're not gonna catch us.
Must go to get us!
Starting from here, let's make a promise.
You and me, let's just be honest, we're gonna run.
Nothing can stop us.
Even the night that falls all around us Soon there will be
laughter and voices Beyond the clouds, over the mountain I
thought it was beyond the clouds We'll run away on roads
that are empty Lights from the airfield Shining above you
Nothing can stop us, no, no, I love you They're not gonna
get us, they're not gonna get us Nothing can stop us, no,
no, I love you
This one's hard, oh my god.
Everything's simple.
Oh my god, that was like my voice is standing.
Our guardian angel, we're a rush ahead.
The crossroads are empty.
I'm not doing it on purpose.
Gonna get us.
My love for you, always forever.
Just you and me.
All else is nothing.
I can't remember this part.
I can't help it.
My voice keeps going up.
I know.
And I'm not doing it.
They don't understand us.
This has been so long.
This has been
so long.
Nothing can stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
They're not gonna get us Nothing can stop us No, no, I love
you They're not gonna get us They're not gonna get us
They're not gonna get us Not gonna get us Not gonna get us
This is gonna be Not gonna get us This is gonna be my sleep
paralysis I know, oh my god Not gonna get us for some reason
during the other paragraphs I couldn't go down like in my
head I was stuck I don't know why I couldn't hear it me too
that's okay no more tattoo no more tattoo no more tattoo
let's do 2010 yeah a thousand years oh my god I saw I saw
tick-tock so in Forks Washington they have because that's
where twilight is they had a twilight festival I think it
was like last weekend and then there was actors that looked
close enough to like close enough to like bella and edward
and they had a full wedding let me see if i could find it it
was kind of crazy because i was like wait this is like i at
first i saw the actors and i was like huh okay and then i
saw like bella not bella but like she looks yeah she looks
just like bella like christian stewart yeah and i was like
what is this twilight way I see I threw a wish in the well.
No, I'll never tell.
Look at this.
Wait, hold on Let's go to Bella and Edward's wedding in
Forge.
Hold on.
That is crazy.
Like let me see.
You have Yeah, Rosalie.
That is crazy.
They look just like a little uncanny from the like you might
think wow That is wild.
That is crazy.
And they like act like she acts like Bella and everything
and I'm like This is so funny.
Like all these people are gathered for Bella and Edward's
wedding, but they're not actually getting Oh my god, that is
crazy.
That is actually insane.
That is insane.
This was literally two days ago.
This lady's crying.
Oh wait, I don't want to like her video.
Oh my god, give her a like.
No, it's okay.
I'm trying to see.
Scrooge.
McDuck.
I wanted to see.
Scrooge McMint.
There was, there was like a better view of the, of, like
kissing.
Oh my god.
I'm like, you're not Robert Pattinson.
POV, you're a guest at Bella and Edward's wedding in Forks
Wah.
Forks Wah.
that's crazy no he literally looks like her dad like the
doctor dad wow that's crazy hold on i'm trying to see it
like she was like so like this is her makeup is like simple
like look at she like looks yeah yeah the way she's like
squinting kind of it's like wow she looks almost like bella
kristen stewart it's so strange but he doesn't look like him
here but from before there was another angle where he did i
know what you mean they don't look like oh they're like
making out oh my god this could be us let's go to forks one
which one was it there was call me maybe we can keep looking
i just saw it and i was like oh call me maybe yeah because
it's fun to sing it is fun i threw a wish in the well don't
ask me i'll never tell i look to you as it fell I'll trade
my soul for a wish, pennies and times for a kiss.
I wasn't looking for this, but now you're in my way.
You're fast.
I was old.
Rip, jeans, skin was showing.
Hot night wind was blowing.
Where you think you're going, baby?
Hey, I just met you, and this is crazy, but here's my
number.
So call me, maybe.
It's hard to look right at you, baby.
So call me maybe.
Hey, I just met you.
And this is crazy.
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
And all the other boys try to chase me.
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
Why do I feel like you would do this?
What?
Be like, I just met you.
This is crazy, but here's my number.
Time for the call.
I took no time with the fall.
You gave me nothing at all.
But you're it.
Maybe in my 30s.
Pig and borrow, not anymore.
First sight and it's real.
I didn't know I would feel it, but it's in my way.
Your stare was holding, ripped jeans skin was showing.
Hot night wind was blowing.
Where you think you're going, baby?
Hey, I just met you.
And this is crazy!
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
It's hard to look right at you, baby.
Here's my number.
So call me maybe.
Hey, I just met you.
And this is crazy.
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
And all the other boys try to chase me.
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
Before you came into my life, I missed you so bad.
Don't touch me.
I missed you so, so bad.
Before you came into my life, I missed you so bad.
And you should know that I missed you so, so bad.
But you laugh.
Cool.
Carly Ray Jepson makes good music now.
Yeah, she always did.
It's hard to look right at you, baby.
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
Hey, I just met you.
And this is crazy.
But here's my number.
So call me maybe.
the other boys try to chase me but here's my number so call
me maybe before you came into my life i missed you so bad i
missed you so bad i missed you so so bad before you came
into my life i missed you so bad and you should know that so
call me maybe yeah yeah i always didn't do music no i i only
We do beauty in a beat.
Wait.
Keep an eye out for Selena.
I'll try my best, okay?
Justin!
Yeah.
Young money.
No, it's Nikki.
Nicki Minaj.
Justin!
Show you off.
Tonight I wanna show you off.
Eh, eh, eh.
I really could have never bought.
We gotta party like it's 30, 12 tonight.
I wanna show you all the finer things in life.
So just forget about the world we're young tonight.
I'm coming for ya.
And all I need is a beauty and a beauty.
Who can make my life complete?
It's all about you When the music makes you move They may do
it like you do Cause uh Cause uh what?
Cause uh what?
What does that mean?
We should do a David Get a song Cause it's really 2000.
Okay, that...
Oh, you'll see.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep, beep.
I don't know.
Where does Nikki Majage come from?
Body rock.
I don't know.
Girl, I can feel your body rock.
Hey, hey, hey.
Take a bow.
You won the hottest ticket now.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
We gotta party like it's 30, 12 tonight.
I wanna show you all the finer things in life.
So just forget about the world we're having tonight.
I'm coming for ya, I'm coming for ya.
So all I need is a beauty and a beat Who can make my life
complete?
And it's all about you When the music makes you move Baby,
do it like you do.
Ugh, ugh.
In time, ink light.
Bitches gonna get on my ink light.
World tour, it's my ten little letters on a big sign.
Justin Bieber, you don't wanna hit him with it either.
Buns out.
Wee!
Come on, keep it out, Selena!
Beauty and the Beast.
Beauty for the East.
Beautiful confession of the priest.
Beauty for the Sheets.
Beauty and the Seas.
I mean, beauty all the beasts.
I want to feel your body rock.
Yeah, yeah, let's go.
Let's go.
Cause all I need the end of the song our life comes
complete.
And it's all now you when the music makes you move.
Baby, do it like you do.
Wow.
Cause, oh.
This right here reminds me.
Ooh, how do you spell that?
D-A-V-I-D.
David.
And then G-U-E-T-T-T-A.
David, get up.
Not titanium.
That's really hard.
Wait, what's titanium?
We should do sexy bitch.
Is titanium the one that's like...
I am titanium.
Yeah.
Oh.
that's it oh my god we should sorry we should do sexy bitch
you trust me the the chorus is damn explicit it says it's
explicit just don't if there's bad words just okay except
sexy bitch oh you know this song yeah you are sexy yeah this
song made me want to party let's go
yes i can see her oh oh because every girl here wants a beer
Oh, she's a diva.
I feel the same and I want to meet her.
You know this one.
They say she's on the lowdown.
It's a rumor and I don't believe them.
They say she needs to slow down.
The baddest thing around town.
She's nothing like the girl you've ever seen before.
Nothing you can compare to your neighborhood.
I'm trying to find the words to describe this girl without
being disrespectful.
The way that booty move and I can't take.
We can pause.
I can pull it close.
I'm trying to find the words to describe this girl without
being disrespectful.
Damn, girl.
Damn, you's a sexy bitch.
That's the most...
A sexy bitch.
That's the not disrespectful.
Damn, you're a sexy bitch.
Damn, girl.
Damn, you's a sexy bitch.
A sexy bitch.
Damn, girl.
It's just this part that made me think of the song each
other.
Because I don't know how it goes.
I don't know how it goes either.
Pause it.
Okay.
Sorry, everybody.
Before it gets more explicit.
Okay.
Not him saying nothing you can compare to a neighborhood
whore.
The songs went crazy.
I want to be disrespectful that he just goes.
She's a sexy bitch.
Damn, girl.
Um...
You want to keep going into 2000s?
Yeah, let's keep going into 2000s.
Actually, I have to pee, so you sing something.
Okay.
I'm going to make you guys cry.
I'm going to sing a sad Nirvana song.
All right, hold on, I got to get out.
Oops.
Oh, my water.
Sorry, my shorts like rode up.
That's fine.
I'm going to go check on Johnny.
Okay.
Here comes Johnny.
Baa, baa, baa, baa, baa, baa, baa, baa, baa, baa.
Here comes one.
Hello, everybody.
Hi, honey.
Ah.
Wait, where's my tongue?
Yeah, what's up?
Okay.
So, right now, what are we doing?
Yeah, she's peeing.
Give her the, give her the, pss, pss, pss, pss.
Damn, girl.
Damn, yous all sexy chick.
Oh, sorry.
I'm going to talk into this microphone.
Sorry if you're hearing me on two microphones.
Damn, you's all sexy chick.
Damn, girl.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom.
Okay, what do I want to do?
I want to go into top.
Am I doing another Nirvana?
Because I feel like I could...
Hmm.
Oh, I'll
do the...
I'll do the Nirvana, okay?
I hope you guys like it.
Let me get an eye patch.
Boom.
Wow.
Load up on guns and bring your friends.
It's fun to lose and to pretend.
She's overboard and self-assured.
Oh, no, I know.
A dirty word.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello,
hello.
With the lights out, it's as dangerous, here we are now.
Entertain us, happy or stupid, and contagious.
Here we are now.
Entertain us, na-na-na-na, and I'll buy now.
I'm a mosquito, my libido, yeah.
You can hear my voice is getting a little wacky.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Yeah.
I think it has a 90s word in it, so I think so.
I gotta not, you know.
I'm worse at what.
I do best and for this gift.
Just a little group has always been and always will until
the end.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello,
hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Will the lights out?
It's less dangerous.
Here we are now.
Entertain us, I feel stupid and contagious.
Entertain us, na-na-na-na-na, an albino, a mosquito, my
libido.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you like me too?
Yeah, it's very comfy.
I want you to give me the link.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I like the bat.
I put an eye patch on you, I hope it's okay.
Oh, are you like so?
You only think there's a word I think you should say.
I'll put it.
It's in the end.
It's a 90th word.
All right, I'm going to try to sing it with my lower.
Ooh, maybe.
If you have it, yeah.
I don't know if I can do all the parts, the higher parts
right now with my voice because it's low.
Yeah, I know.
And I forget just why I taste, oh yeah, I guess.
makes me smile.
I found it hard.
It's hard to find a well, whatever, never mind.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello,
hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
When the lights out, it's less dangerous.
Here we are now.
entertain us I feel stupid and contagious here we are now
entertain us na na na na I don't mind it all I'm a mosquito
my libido a denial a denial a denial a denial
A denial.
I will say when I first started singing a few years ago,
four songs that I was exhausted.
And I'm like, yeah, my voice is tired.
Now we're two and a half hours in.
Yeah.
Baby.
How many more songs you want to do?
What's the big river in Egypt called?
Denial.
A denial.
I'm denying.
We got some of my chemical romance.
I sang The Sharpest Lives earlier.
Yeah.
Um, we can do a couple more.
My, yeah, my voice is also starting to give out, you guys.
So, you have to play video games tomorrow.
I have to play video games.
I'm playing video games.
Denial.
And I'm going to walk around your hood and smoke cigarettes.
No.
Oh.
I mean, you won't be with me when you're going to stream.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I mean.
No.
don't do that don't oh johnny what's up johnny hey what's up
you want to on the mic yeah johnny hold on it's oh can you
make sure i don't pull it out yeah johnny johnny johnny come
here johnny what do you have to say it was like he just went
um i should like have this second mic hooked up for whenever
johnny come and I could just because my mic my current mic
is like on a stand so you guys I can't really move it to
like get to Johnny but if I had this one that Matara is
using and then I just have it off until Johnny comes and
then it's like Johnny Mike Johnny the mic is hot and he's to
get a mic to attach to Johnny if you had like a little cat
collar oh my god he would be so annoying and then they'd
like hear him just pee or eat yeah he eats and he pees as
cats should do i don't know what do you want to do how many
more songs i'm good let's see somebody said more rock more
rock um let's see what else they have in the 2000s in the
2000s that justin beaver song was a good catch it like got
me pumped up it was fun 2010s or 2000s let's try 2000s
because we just did 2010s okay okay okay uh we're breaking
free let's see meow meow he's meowing
oh my nose My homes, my home, my home, my home.
My lovely lady home.
Check it out.
Come here.
Hello.
My dream.
Here.
What?
What do you have to say?
You're like interviewing him.
And then how did that make you feel?
What are you doing?
My little baby boy.
Where are the other songs?
I only got a few of them.
Oh, my baby.
You want my baby, you want my baby, you want my baby.
Rock and roll, hard rock.
Music spiritual music, lol.
Can you put the mic by his purring?
Can you get your purr?
He's got a power box really loud.
So it's an alternative.
Mr. Bootside.
Oh, Lips of an Angel, we can close on that one.
Because that's, like, your song.
Oh, my goodness.
Yes.
He's climbing up me.
No, please.
He might start, when he's been, he's been, like, gagging
when sitting in my lap like this.
He's not going to throw up.
I'm going to look at his little, I know.
He's, like, crossing his legs.
He's so polite.
Oh, oh, yeah, I know you like this one.
Oh, you might leave.
Oh, sorry, buddy.
Here's a Christmas song for y'all.
Gotta sing it lower, like he sings it.
Dead, I am the one exterminating sun, slipping through the
trees, strangling the breeze.
the sky watching angels cry while they slowly turn
conquering the world.
Dig through the ditches and burn through the witches.
I slam in the back of my Dracula.
Oh, he's drooling on me.
Dead I am the bull spreading from the full.
We can want you need nowhere as you bleed
The rat feast upon the cat tender Is the burnt dying as you
purr Dig through the ditches and burn through the witches I
slam in the back of my Dracula Dig through the ditches and
burn through the witches I slam in the back of my Dracula
Do it, baby.
Burn like an animal.
Dead I am the life.
Dig into the skin.
Knuckle, crack the bone.
21 to win.
Dead I am the dog.
How girl, how?
you cry, devil on your back, I can never die.
Dig through the ditches and burn through the witches.
I slam in the back of my Dracula.
Dig through the witches and burn through the...
Do it, baby.
Do it,
baby.
it, baby.
Burn like an animal.
Dig through the ditches and burn through the witches.
I slam in the back of my Dracula.
I dig through the ditches and burn through the witches.
Let's go get dinner.
Yes.
What are you in the mood for?
Did you want to try Italiano?
Italiano.
Fettuccini.
Maybe.
Okay.
Honestly, not to be like that, but you know when we first
get to Japan and every time I tell people, don't talk to me
for the first few days, I'm only going to have sushi.
I'm just saying.
Oh, wait.
So you're saying you want sushi?
I mean, obviously it's your choice.
We just got sushi.
I mean, if you can't make a choice and you ask me my
opinion.
No, no, no, no, no.
I just, I'm the same way.
Was he attacking me?
Am I crazy?
Okay, he's not attacking me.
I'm the same way, but with pasta.
Spaghetti and ketchup.
Yeah, no, ketchup.
Oh, I hate the meat.
I love spaghetti and ketchup.
Why are you looking for another song?
I don't know.
One last song.
Do you want to do closing time?
I will follow you into the dark.
No, oh, I will follow you into the dark somewhere.
Okay, then.
No, let's do closing time.
Okay.
Because it's like, it's a little more.
I want you.
Which one is it?
Tom, semi-somic, semi-sonic.
Okay, there we go.
All right, everybody, you know the drill.
You know the drill, get out.
If you have any, Chris, if you have any dollar-dollar bills,
give him over to Mint.
Me.
No, I don't need them.
Thank you for being here.
But you can't stay here.
You gotta get out of here, everybody.
Get out, get out, go, go, go.
Closing time, open all the doors and let you out to the
world.
Sorry, I'm bad at timing.
Closing time, turn all of the lights on every boy and every
girl.
Sorry, we're drunk.
Acos party, that's all.
One last call for alcohol.
Also finish your whiskey or beer.
Can I have alcohol tonight please?
Closing time.
Cool, cool, thank you.
You don't have to go home, but you can't stay here.
Get out!
I know who I want to take me home.
Take me home, take me home.
Sorry everybody, we're going to have spaghetti with ketchup.
Closing time.
Time for you to go out to the place where you will be from.
This room won't be open till your brothers or your sisters
come.
So gather up your jacket.
Move it to the exit!
I hope you have found a friend.
Closing time.
Every new beginning comes from some other beginnings.
That's right, it's over.
Yeah!
I know who I want to take me home.
who I want to take me home take me home
yeah I'm really bad with timings sometimes when I record I
actually have to do this like this with my hand that's why I
kind of like yeah otherwise like I fall out of the rhythm
all the time constantly bouncing when I was doing boom the
ghost because the song is so pointy I was on my tippy toes I
was like doing this on my tippy toes yeah to kind of like
stay with it oh
my god imagine they have 11 pasta.
They had 11 pasta near where I was four.
Yeah.
Sorry, go take it with a pinky.
Thank you.
Closing time, time for you to go out to the places you will
be from.
Know who I want to take me home.
I know who I want to take me home.
Take me home.
You're home.
Oh.
I know who I want to take me home.
Take me home.
All about fun.
Thanks everybody for watching.
Thanks for bringing me home.
B miracle.
Remember, your sleeper.
Oh, a demon is gonna sound like this.
Uh,
closing time.
Every new beginning comes from some other beginnings.
And...
Did you guys see the Good Smile announcement?
Did you guys see?
If you are curious, it is not in Fumo style.
It is just, it is just, it's just, it's just like a, it's
not even, it's a different style of plushie from my previous
one.
So it's not Fumo style if you were worried about that
because if you got the Fumo before.
It's completely new.
Completely new.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Just in case you were worried about that.
Yippee!
Okay.
Yeah.